hey guys it is the 24th of every today
my name is Jess McDonald and do watching
games like me we can probably expect
batman arkham knight to come with some
serious grit since it's been rated M for
Mature unlike its predecessors well
Arkham City and Arkham Asylum were both
classified t14 Arkham Knight has upped
the ante there's not been any Content
description published from the
Entertainment Software Rating board so
we don't know exactly why the game is
rated M as yet but Rocksteady have said
they aren't surprised game director
Sefton Hill told IGN it would have been
wrong to water down the game and deliver
a story we didn't believe in to keep the
game mass market or enable it for more
people we feel that's the wrong way to
go about it we said we love the story
and we don't want to jeopardize that
we're not including gratuitous blood or
swearing we want to deliver a true end
with no compromises and it takes us to
some dark places GTA fans who prefer PC
just cannot catch a break with yet
another delay hitting the pc version of
GTA 5 here's a history lesson the pc
version was originally supposed to come
out in fall 2014 that changed too late
january 2015 which then became march 24
and now it's april 14 rockstar throwing
more GTA online money at their fans
specifically 200 grand apiece to help
say she ate them but it's hard not to be
frustrated with this one Rockstar have
simply said that they need more time to
polish the game and given the rocky
launch GTA 4 head on PC that might not
be such a bad thing the developer also
announced that heists for GTA online
will land on March 10 and they unveiled
the minimum and recommended pc specs for
GTA 5 which you can check out on
gamespot on the back of the possibility
that we're going to be getting a new
rock band game it seems a new guitar
hero may
also be joining its ranks you know it's
hypothetical room at ranks according to
a new report from kotaku UK who cite two
independent sources Activision will
announce a new guitar hero game for Xbox
one and ps4 at e3 this year the last
installment in the series was 2010
warriors of rock this new one will
apparently sport a more realistic look
and Activision will release new guitar
peripherals it suggested that we'll be
able to pick up this upcoming Guitar
Hero game before the years out let me
know down in the comments if you buy
into this rumor and if you're a rock
band fan or guitar here then you can add
the games but we've got youth on a
lawsuit for nvidia and valves new VR
headset those are all the things that I
have to tell you about today ads always
do let me know what you cared about and
eye catching things on tomorrow